[Music]
i think biology is so critical for
everybody to learn
because
it defines
who we are
as human beings as animals it defines
the whole animal kingdom and then it
goes on to define the whole plant
kingdom
the insect kingdom
understanding those
principles of how
living things
are organized is not only a beautiful
thing to understand but it gives deep
insight and deep appreciation
for our own lives
and i think that is the core of why i
find it so
important that everybody study this this
beautiful
area of of academia biology is super
important to learn for so many reasons
but the reason that stands out most to
me is well
the rarity of life outside of our little
corner of the universe
you might not know what i mean but stick
with me for a sec so so we are
positively surrounded by biology every
day here on earth but we haven't
encountered life or even evidence of
life outside of this little blue marvel
even though there is so much cosmic real
estate out there
life
is really complicated and that goes for
starting and sustaining life
somehow ancient organisms made it work
here but that doesn't mean that it's
easy all of us carry on this legacy of
life finding a way but one day
maybe life will have to find a way
through us
maybe earth becomes inhospitable for
some reason and we have to figure out
how to live somewhere else on that day
success will depend on how well we
understand the heaps of obstacles that
the stubbornness of life has already
overcome
you